cette incertitude et toutes les
perturbations qui sont causés par les
blocus on peut se demander si ça nuit à
l'image du canada à sa réputation auprès
des investisseurs
est ce que les entreprises voudront
continuer d'investir au canada on en
parle avec geneviève dufour qui est
spécialisé en droit international à
l'université de sherbrooke et robert
asselin qui est économiste premier
vice-président du conseil canadien des
affaires bonsoir à vous deux
robert asselin d'abord évoqué la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence est ce que le
premier ministre avait d'autre choix
je ne pense pas qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'autres choix ce moment ci d'une
urgence nationale
je pense qu'ils requièrent un leadership
national il n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres
options à sa disposition
c'est une crise qui perdure monsieur
fillion depuis trois semaines pour nous
montrer les incidences économiques c'est
majeur et je pense le gouverneur
national fédéral avait un rôle à jouer
en leadership
un exercice qui viennent pas certains
diront que ça a pris un peu de temps
cela dit monsieur la semaine sur les
institutions financières
ciblées les institutions financières qui
vont cesser d'offrir des services
financiers aux entités qui finance les
barrages et légaux les camionneurs
également qu'ils utilisent leur semi
remorque dans les barrages vont voir
leurs comptes d'entreprises jolie les
assurances suspendu est ce que c'est la
manière efficace de mettre fin à ces
barrages
femme à barbe bien s'est construit
monsieur fillion vous savez à ce
mécanisme qui existe une groupie drague
qu'on appelle une traque qui est exercée
par une agence indépendante qui relève
du ministère des finances qui suit déjà
les transactions suspectes au niveau du
blanchiment d'argent supérieur est un
mécanisme qui fonctionne bien donc on va
se servir de ça pour arriver enfin
convenu de décrire comme un espoir
important des transports factuel jeunes
d'hier dufour est ce que les blocages
affecte la réputation économique auprès
des investisseurs étrangers selon vous
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
d'abord et avant tout le canada a une
très bonne réputation auprès des
investisseurs on est un peu un modèle en
matière d'investissements directs
jl canada offre des conditions qui sont
habituellement prévisible assez stable
il permet aussi d'avoir une porte vers
les états unis donc le canada c'est une
terre d'accueil pour les investissements
et c'est important pour vous faut aussi
dire qu'au niveau du commerce
international on peut dire que le canada
est un bon partenaire
nos manoeuvres douanes sont prévisibles
sont transparents automatisé
efficace mais effectivement vous avez
raison le blocus et l'occupation nos
points d'entrée de sortie
l'inaction du gouvernement fédéral ou du
moins son action très tardive a
probablement eu
le potentiel de jeter une ombre sur
notre capacité à être une bonne terre
d'accueil des investissements du
commerce international du moins au
niveau de la prévisibilité et dans un
contexte en plus ce geneviève du four ou
le canada depuis des années a été
obligée de négocier avec d'abord un
gouvernement
de celles à suivre celui d'un autre et
maintenant un gouvernement
protectionnistes comme celui de joe
biden ça tombe un bien mauvais moment
que le canada porte d'entrée vers les
états unis donnent l'image
d'être attentistes en quelque sorte face
à des manifestants qui bloquent la plus
grosse le plus gros lien commercial
entre les deux pays
effectivement vous avez raison les
années 30 on en a beaucoup parlé mais fo
fait du mal au canada de manière
épouvantable
par exemple on a conclu un accord de
libre échange avec l'europe dans le
cadre duquel on s'attendait à ce qui a
énormément d'investissement
d'investisseurs européens on s'est rendu
compte que la plupart d'entre eux
avaient été très frileux dîner installée
au canada parce qu'ils n'avaient pas la
porte d'entrée qui voulaient par les
états unis monsieur paris donne est
arrivé au pouvoir sont sa politique buy
american son buy america act vient
encore une fois faire en sorte que nos
investisseurs vont difficilement trouver
un
marcher dans les grands projets
d'infrastructure dans l'eau ce qui va se
faire aux autres mais dans les
prochaines années on n'avait vraiment
pas besoin de ce taux vraiment pas
besoin d'ajouter encore une incertitude
une imprévisibilité franchement
gouvernement aurait dû agir beaucoup
plus rapidement et on peut quand même
s'étonner que ce soit des groupes
des groupes privés commerciaux qui est à
demander l'injonction vendredi on peut
aussi dire que franchement ça a pris du
temps avant qu'on déloge les
manifestants vous parliez de 40 une
arrestation
pourquoi ça pas été plus rapide en main
toy boy de earth ainsi fait d'une
manière pacifique et donc relativement
effectivement robert asselin vous vous
en pensez quoi sur la réputation et
l'adoption de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence à change quoi dans le fond sur
le plan économique et commercial à
partir de maintenant mais vous savez
quand vous la mairie appelle le premier
canadien pour lui dire il est inquiet
les échanges commerciaux entre les deux
pays je pense que c'est un signe qu'il
faut voir de l'art est grave je pense
que ça nécessite une réponse de notre
gouvernement national c'est ce qu'on
fait et comme madame le dit si bien
cette confiance mais elle est fragile on
en relation avec les américains de
longue durée mais dans une époque où le
protectionnisme est si important avec
monsieur byden c'est elle avec monsieur
jobs il peut pas y porte il faut pas
être naïf par rapport à ce que les états
veulent faire pour protéger ramener la
production domestique dans leur pays et
dans cette optique là il fallait mettre
fin à ce qui est arrivé
sur le pont à woods avait ramené la
primauté du droit l'orb comme on mène au
cours des derniers jours mais ce que le
mal est déjà fait geneviève dufour est
ce que les états unis pourraient
utiliser ce qui vient d'arriver pour
changer les règles du jeu de nos
échanges commerciaux
nous encore de l'hybride l'accord de
l'évolution je viens d'être concluant on
va pas leur ennemi de rire
j'ai pas l'impression que ça va changer
à court terme la question vous l'avez
bien posée est ce que les
investissements vont être plus frileux
est-ce qu'ils vont pas de décider
d'aller directement aux états unis
s'installer plutôt que de venir au
canada pour avoir la porte d'accès par
les états unis mais encore là c'est
une pierre de plus mais sinon
franchement c'est ça fait des années
depuis le début des années tout en bloc
que c'est très très
instable bien jean-pierre dufour merci
robert asselin merci beaucoup pour cette
analyse ce soir avec nous un fou mais
c'est pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit